hello and welcome to gamespot of Thrones
you are watching just a small segment of
a much larger program where we discuss
in depth Game of Thrones season 6
episode 1 the red woman if you'd like to
see the full episode be sure to head to
youtube.com slash gamespot beware of
spoilers
right so in season five we know that
ruse legitimized Ramsay's who's no
longer Ramsay snow mmm he is a true
Bolton so now that he's alone no longer
a bastard it would make sense that he'd
wants to to keep his new title he's now
the true heir to his father you could
inherit all of everything the flayed man
owns so now the Santa's escaped his hold
on that has weakened they needed Sansa
for the north and he needed to produce
an heir with Sansa so in this episode
Roose makes quite a subtle threat to
Ramsey with that sense that you won't be
able to produce an heir and without an
heir well let's hope the maesters are
right and Lady Walder's carrying a boy I
think the Ramsey will be so scared of
losing his his new role in the Bolton
family and he's also quite insane
especially with the grief that is
probably going through after feeding his
you know X to the dogs I'm sure I'm sure
that knocked him for six is somewhat I
think he will be driven to kill lady
Walda the unborn claimant to his new
title and possibly his father who let it
be noted doesn't appear in any season
six trailers which might mean is part
isn't very big you might be mind dying
episode 2 and not appear in the next day
and you see Ramsey at the head of the
armies you do also you see Ramsay
cleaning his his little blade blade
almost as if he just used it and he does
what is related to he does have ultimate
daddy issues and when you've got daddy
issues what's what's the only way that
can end killing and you surfing your
father whoa psychology thank you dr.
Freud but I like that they're a lot I
kind of hope that happens as well oh
yeah poor lady Walda yeah I mean she
hasn't anything wrong she just you know
had a kid with a maniac
you